Hey Matkin, sorry, dass meine Kamera nicht
funktioniert hat. Ich möchte zuerst sagen, dass dein
Videoclip der beste ist, den ich je gesehen habe. Nun,
kommen wir zu meiner Frage, wie
du all diese Leute dazu gebracht hast, Jens
gleich zu sein, danke  Sie für Ihre
Antwort, nur Nummer zwei bei irgendeinem High-Tech-
Zeug, Mann mit der hypnotisierenden
Musik in der Hinterhand, er ist wie der
Guru des Cyberspace, okay, ich fange einfach
damit an, also nur Nummer zwei, es ist ein
verrücktes Auto, okay, Ken nicht getroffen  Matkin bedeutet in meiner
Sprache etwas anderes. Wenn
du auf die Toilette gehst, machst du eine Nummer. Du
musst nicht sagen, dass die Frage ja war.
Ja, okay, also ähm, ja, du erinnerst dich, wie wir das
bekommen
haben  Zweitens war es wirklich
harte Arbeit, also müssen wir fast sechs Monate lang durch
ganz Europa reisen. Wir
klopfen an Türen und sagen den Leuten, dass Sie
Teil dieses Projekts sein wollen.
Wir werden alle vereinen. Wir kommen nach
Hamburg, hier, Köln, Düsseldorf, England,
überall  Irland nehmen wir uns also wirklich vor
viel Energie, also mussten wir uns
sechs Monate von der Arbeit freinehmen, um es zu machen, aber wir haben
sie alle zusammengebracht, nur Nummer zwei,
okay, das ist eine große, fette Lüge, wie wir es normalerweise
gemacht haben oder wie sie es wirklich gemacht haben, war,
dass wir den Produzenten und den
Choreografen hatten  das ging und reiste
um den Kontinent und sie taten
das ungefähr sechs Monate lang, ich würde sagen,
eher 34, und sie klopften an keine
Tür und sie kündigten einfach jeden in
jeder Stadt an, in der sie waren, wenn
jemand kommen und zu Matt-Calls tanzen wollte
neue Single und dann, als sie wie
ein paar tausend Leute kamen, stand der
Choreograf da und zeigte
ihnen, wie man die Tänze macht, und dann nehmen sie das auf
, und dann sammeln sie das
ganze Filmmaterial und nehmen es zurück, hier
ist, was er sagt, Geschichte  ist Caca und was
ich sage, ist wahr, hör nicht auf ihn
gebildet